Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Imaginez-vous dans les 30 glorieuses,
les années 60.
Tout va bien.
Vous nagez dans l’opulence.
Il n’y a aucun souci
de ressources ou d’emploi.
Le pouvoir d’achat augmente,
la voiture se démocratise,
l’énergie ne coûte pas cher.
Bon, ce n’est pas évident de se projeter,
mais tous les voyants sont verts
pour développer l’habitat pavillonnaire,
et comme disait si bien Alphonse Allais,
« construire la ville à la campagne
car l’air y est plus pur. »
Et ça fait un peu plus rêver que les
grands ensembles construits par l'État
dans un contexte d’après-guerre,
souvent baigné d’urgence.
Et d’ailleurs, pour l’État,
c’est bénéfique.
Plutôt que de construire, laissez
les gens construire eux-mêmes.
C’est alors tout un système économique
et politique qui s’invente
pour promouvoir ce modèle d’initiative
privée, celui de la propriété.
Jusque-là, tout va bien.
Sauf que la fabrique de l’habitat, comme
beaucoup d’autres processus d’ailleurs,
elle s'industrialise.
Et elle s’industrialise
en clonant des pavillons partout,
les mêmes qu’on voit aujourd’hui
en banlieue parisienne,
dans le sud de la France
ou dans le Grand Est.
Le problème, c’est que 60 ans après,
c’est devenu notre référentiel.
Le rêve pavillonnaire est toujours
celui de la grande majorité des Français.
Et même, il est enraciné auprès des
politiques, mais aussi des constructeurs.
Et aujourd’hui,
il est souvent moins cher et plus facile
de construire sur des champs
plutôt que de réhabiliter,
de transformer ce qui existe déjà,
donc les sols, les bâtiments
et donc de vivre en ville.
Alors posons-nous la question : est-ce que
le choix de faire construire sa maison,
c’est vraiment notre choix ?
Est-ce qu’il est vraiment guidé
par nos envies et nos pratiques ?
Et à long terme, ça donne quoi ?
Car où est-ce qu’on trouve
de grands terrains, pas chers,
pour y construire une maison
en plein milieu ?
Forcément loin du cœur des villes,
donc loin des services, des emplois,
des commerces, des loisirs.
Et si la voiture a permis hier
de créer les lotissements,
aujourd’hui, elle est
la seule manière d’en sortir
rien que pour aller chercher son pain.
Ce qui, indépendamment du reste,
démultiplie forcément
le coût de ce mode de vie.
Prenons un peu de recul.
Schématiquement, ce modèle
se développe depuis près de 60 ans
sous forme de cellules de pavillonnaires
qui se répètent, pullulent
et s’éloignent toujours plus.
Avec parfois les cellules
de zones commerciales.
Et c’est un système
qu’on appelle mono-fonctionnel
où chaque fonction, chaque activité
est isolée dans une zone
que j’appelle donc cellule,
mais aussi dans un moment de la journée.
Le soir à la maison
et la journée au supermarché.
Surtout pas de frottements
ni d'interactions.
Et ce sont les routes,
toujours plus longues,
qui irriguent et relient,
mais, de fait, qui séparent.
Maintenant, soyons pragmatiques.
Si les villes grossissent,
c’est au détriment des campagnes.
Et en 60 ans d’étalement urbain,
c’est un quart des sols agricoles
qui ont disparu par artificialisation.
C’est l’équivalent de deux à trois fois
la surface de Paris
qui est grignoté chaque année.
C’est beaucoup, non ?
Et pourtant, c'est invisible à nos
yeux et on en entend peu parler.
Une des raisons pour lesquelles
le message ne passe pas,
c’est que les spécialistes ont encore
du mal à s’entendre sur les définitions
et notamment le mot « artificialisation ».
Vous voyez à quoi ça tient ?
Mais il y a quand même une réalité
physique qu'on ne peut pas nier.
La Terre, c’est une structure finie.
Elle n’est pas extensible et le sol
est une ressource non renouvelable.
Donc au même titre que l’eau, il pourrait
être judicieux de l’économiser
si on veut préserver
notre autonomie alimentaire
en préservant nos terres cultivables,
la biodiversité,
l’eau potable et le climat.
Vous allez me dire : « L’équation
n’est pas simple à résoudre
car la population augmente et il faut
bien que tout le monde soit logé. »
Mais elle n’augmente pas aussi vite
que la consommation des sols.
Preuve qu'on peut faire mieux.
Comme pour tout,
avant de changer la pratique,
commençons par comprendre,
par porter les choses à la conscience,
ce sera moins douloureux et plus efficace.
Et vous allez voir qu’économiser le sol,
c’est plus fun que ça en a l’air
car c’est l’opportunité de repenser
nos habitats et même nos villes,
plus en cohérence avec nos modes de vie
qui ont évolué et qui vont encore évoluer.
On va y aller par échelons
en repartant du pavillon.
Le pavillon, schématiquement,
c’est une boîte
implantée en retrait
des limites de terrain,
pour marquer la frontière avec le voisin.
L’isolement, il est garanti par le jardin,
dont la majeure partie
est pourtant à la vue de tous.
Je ne sais pas si vous l’avez remarqué,
mais c’est souvent sur une infime
partie du jardin, à l’abri des regards,
qu’on mangera, qu’on jouera,
qu’on jardinera, bref, qu’on vivra.
Imaginons maintenant supprimer ces
bandes latérales et le jardin de devant.
On ne perd ni en usage ni en intimité
même si le jardin, il est moins grand.
Ça donne des boîtes collées
qu’on appelle maisons mitoyennes,
dont l’économie d’un mur favorise
en plus l’efficacité énergétique.
Ensuite, le pavillon est en moyenne
deux fois plus grand que l'appartement.
Il est calibré sur un modèle familial,
nucléaire et conjugal
qui déjà ne correspond pas à tous
et surtout qui explose :
enfants qui partent, qui reviennent,
parents qui se séparent,
parents âgés qui reviennent
chez leurs enfants.
Par contre, en face de ça,
la boîte du pavillon, son contenant,
de par sa rigidité, elle l’empêche
de s’adapter à ces flux.
Car en général,
on ne détruit pas une extension
une fois qu'on n'en a plus besoin.
Et si on rendait les habitats évolutifs
pour qu’ils puissent s’adapter
à ces changements de la vie ?
Eh bien, cette souplesse est techniquement
réalisable dans l'habitat collectif,
dont l’enveloppe compacte
plusieurs boîtes d’habitat individuel
absorbées par des entre-deux communs.
Je vais vous donner un exemple,
même s’il y en a plein d’autres
et que ce n’est pas nouveau.
L’agence d’architecture Mayo, à Barcelone,
a conçu un ensemble de 22 logements
comme un système de pièces neutres,
donc sans destination figée à l’avance,
et disposées autour de la cuisine.
Ça multiplie les possibilités
d’aménagement, de personnalisation
et donc d’appropriation
de chaque appartement.
En plus, il peut être étendu ou rétréci
pour s’adapter aux besoins
en agrégeant certaines pièces
de manière durable ou plus temporaire.
C’est vrai que ça demande d’échanger
un peu plus avec nos voisins
que pour demander un tournevis.
Et ça nous demande, acteurs de la ville,
de réfléchir davantage
au montage économique, juridique
et de gestion du logement.
Mais preuve que c’est possible,
ce projet, il est réalisé et il vit.
On peut même aller plus loin.
Si les limites spatiales
entre notre bulle d’intimité
et l’espace que l’on est prêt
à partager évoluaient ;
si, au lieu de se limiter à la route,
comme dans le modèle pavillonnaire,
les espaces partagés pouvaient
s’étendre à l’entrée et au jardin
comme dans les logements intermédiaires,
ou encore jusqu’à la cuisine,
au salon et à la buanderie,
eh bien, cette mutualisation
permettrait d’économiser
et de partager les coûts énergétiques,
mais aussi l’achat d’un équipement,
d’une surface et donc des sols.
Les colocations, coliving
et autres habitats participatifs
prouvent que de nouvelles domesticités
se mettent en place.
Je suis persuadée que leur engouement
n’est pas seulement économique.
C’est un vrai désir pour une vie
en partie collective
qui est largement exprimé
par la jeune génération.
Enfin si déjà, au lieu
de revendiquer un seul rêve,
on cherchait plutôt à diversifier
au maximum les formes d’habitat.
D’abord parce qu’il n’y a pas
d’habitat générique
qu’on pourrait calquer partout,
étant donné qu’il doit être réellement
contextualisé en fonction de chaque site.
Ensuite diversifier pour prendre en compte
les préférences d’un maximum de gens
et pouvoir répondre à
l’hétérogénéité de nos modes de vie.
En tout cas, pour réussir
à compenser la maison individuelle,
il est certain que l’habitat collectif
doit a minima répondre
à des critères d’usage
qui paraissent si évidents et qui
sont pourtant trop peu respectés :
terrasse bien dimensionnée, vraie cuisine,
vraie ouverture permettant
la lumière, la ventilation
et donnant de vraies vues sur l’extérieur,
une vraie hauteur sous plafond,
des espaces prévus pour les rangements,
une bonne isolation thermique et phonique.
Et en plus de tout ça,
l’habitat collectif doit
répondre aux fantasmes
que la maison individuelle ne permet pas
en étant modulable, partagé et hybride
entre usagers consentants
et en recréant ce lien, cette proximité
qui a tendance à se perdre
dans le modèle pavillonnaire.
Une fois qu’on a dit ça, qu’est-ce
qu’on fait des zones pavillonnaires ?
Je vous rassure,
on n’en fait surtout pas table rase.
Non, il faut simplement arrêter
d'en construire.
Et par contre, tâche à nous de réparer
les zones existantes :
les rattacher à la ville,
aux boulangeries, aux bureaux de poste,
en améliorant leur desserte
et que cette desserte puisse
se faire autrement qu’en voiture.
D’optimiser leur espace en utilisant
les friches, les interstices
pour y insérer là où c’est pertinent,
de nouvelles boulangeries,
de nouveaux cabinets médicaux et même,
pourquoi pas, de nouveaux habitants.
De manière très pragmatique,
pour éviter que la ville grossisse
de manière linéaire,
il faut plutôt refaire la ville
sur la ville
en intensifiant la ville qui existe déjà
et en commençant par les logements
inutilisés ou vacants qui sont invisibles
et pourtant si nombreux.
Faire la ville compacte et sur la ville,
ça permet naturellement de rapprocher,
voire de mutualiser des fonctions
dans un même lieu
et dans un même bâtiment.
Et qui dit forme urbaine plus compacte,
dit plus de place pour le vide.
C’est ce vide qui fait
la beauté de la ville.
Il faut absolument
le laisser et le soigner.
Car le vide, c'est nos espaces verts,
nos potagers, nos circulations.
C'est l'espace public qui nous permet
de nous arrêter, de nous reposer,
de nous rencontrer,
de nous retrouver par envie,
par surprise, par dépit
ou même encore de rester anonyme.
Le vide, c’est vraiment cet entre-deux
qui nous permet d’absorber l’imprévu.
L’espace public,
il doit nous donner la possibilité
d’être l’extension de l’espace privé.
Bref, nous devons tous et toutes
nous réapproprier
nos choix d’habitat
et notre vision de la ville
pour les rendre plus cohérents
avec les enjeux actuels.
Parce que la ville, ce n’est pas
une machine ni un objet fini,
mais c’est bien un organisme vivant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)